the Joe Rogan experience I want to go to
the Kentucky Derby need to let's just
cross a acid I'm so down for that and
where didn't wear suits like Dumb and
Dumber
sloshed off [ __ ] bourbon next year I
take acid and go in the Derby that
Buffalo Trace distillery or whatever
that oh yeah dude I drink whiskey I mean
yeah almost every day now it's happened
getting there I don't know you getting
older can I get the palate for whiskey
really a lot of stress about cigars do
you like cigars nope no I think yet I
like olives I used to hate all this love
olives now and whiskey dude I don't know
why is that's hilarious
what whiskey is this I'm not a little
more by the way what's it called again
Jamie why Anton's Blanton's it is
delicious I have no idea it could have
been anybody could have brought it all
remember honestly this can't be cheap
just feelin this goblet this grenade
goblet they got this game of thrones
goblet is sick speed so give me Johnnie
Walker white Walker whiskey shot at
night Veldman white Walker whiskey bring
that [ __ ] up Jane white Walker whiskey
limited emissions no in addition I'm not
drinking that
zombie piss the bottles so sick I don't
want people touching it really oh it's a
collector's item ed didn't we collecting
bottles of Game of Thrones oh I got that
[ __ ] bro is it sold out damn Enzo
Ferrari what the other one not for you -
happy birthday yeah dude how dope is
that's pretty cool Johnnie Walker's a
white Walker yeah but what do you want
to be aligned with the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the realm come on Johnnie
Walker I wish they would have Johnny
Walker with the Nazis I wish they with
Johnny Walker Nazi vodka would you would
you buy that no why the [ __ ] you buying
white Walker whiskey that's a white
Walker bourbon or whatever it is there's
a gift bro
[ __ ] that he can't eat a white Walker
you have my frame bro for me are gonna
get hammered
yeah
- stick around yeah yeah yeah juice some
arrows shoot some arrows getting the
flow tank relax my friends relax